INTRO GOLDEN MOUSTACHE
Regarder son ami sous la douche avec du désir,
Est-ce que c'est gay ?
Non, il a juste un bon shampooing
Renifler le caleçon sale d'un ami rugbyman,
Est-ce que c'est gay ?
Non, c'est pour économiser une machine !
Non, ça n'a rien de sexuel, d'envisager un jacuzzi sans vis-à-vis
Non, ça n'a rien d'excitant,
Un jardinier aux pectoraux luisants
Non, non
Est-ce que c'est gay ?(x2)
Je ne crois pas, non (x3)...
Objectivement, non
Ce n'est pas gay...
Donne-moi ta main !
Oublie tous les clichés !
Enlève ton slip,
Donne-moi ta main !
Plus besoin de douter,
C'est juste de l'amitié
Masser délicatement un pote, afin que la crème pénètre,
Est-ce que c'est gay ?
Non, c'est juste pour bien l'hydrater
Caresser le visage d'un homme en lui disant "Je t'aime",
Est-ce que c'est gay ?
(Pas du tout)
C'est pour qu'il reprenne confiance en lui.
Non, ça na rien de tendancieux,
D'observer un individu qui se suce-tente
Ça n'a rien de romantique,
Un mec viril qui collectionne les seaux d'eau (sodo)
(Naan)x2
Est-ce que c'est gay ?
Je ne crois pas, non
Je ne crois pas...
Ha oui je ne pense pas non
Ça n'est pas gay...
Donne-moi ta main !
Oublie tous les clichés !
Enlève ton slip-
Donne-moi ta main !
Plus besoin de douter
Et suce moi la-mitié !
L 'amitié !
Dès le départ, c'était, c'était ce- c'était ce que j'voulais dire l'amitié
Oui !
Avouer à sa famille qu'on est homosexuel,
Est-ce que c'est gay ?
Non, c'est juste bien savoir communiquer avec son entourage,
afin d'être honnête à propos de l'amour qu'on a envers les hommes,
parce qu'on est gay
Huuuh ?
Carlito: Taper "Gaypics" dans google au lieu de s'abonner à notre chaîne est-ce que c'est gay?
Je ne crois pas, non
Et embrasser une personne du même sexe tout les vendredis
au lieu de regarder le lab est-ce que c'est gay?
Objectivement
Non
*Hum... Je dois commencer quand vous me dites "top"?*
*Commencez quand vous voulez mon enfant...*